هند هذه الشايا التي هي في اجساد عائله
وائل هي نفسها في جسدي هي نفسها في جسد
شيرين ابو
عاقل الصوت الذي سمعناه للتو هو صوت
كريستين عصي صحفيه من وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه كانت تغطي مع ست صحفيين اخرين
القصف المتكرره لجنوب لبنان من طرف
اسرائيل يوم الث ع من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي تعرض هؤلاء الصحفيون لاستهداف
مباشرين الضربه
الاولى ادت الى استشهاد الصحفي في رويترز
عصام العبد الله واصابه كريستين عاصي
اصابه بالغه نجم عنها بتر ساقها اما
الضربه
الثانيه فقد استهدفت فريق الجزيره وادت
الى اصابه الزميله المراسله كارمن جو خدار
والزميل المصور ال براخ التقينا زميلتنا
المراسله كارمن جو خدار التي نجت من
الاستهداف وسالنا كارمن لماذا برايك يتم
استهداف الصحفيين السبب يعود الى ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يريد ان يفرض روايته
في الاحداث هذا الامر في غزه في الضفه
الغربيه في القدس المحتله وايضا في جنوب
لبنان فرض هذه الروايه ورفض اي روايه اخرى
اي روايه حقيقيه تطلع الناس وتطلع العالم
كله على ما يجري اكان داخل فلسطين او اكان
في جنوب لبنان هو امر يؤذي الاحتلال اولا
لناحيه تراجع
التاييد ومعرفه حقيقه ما يجري وحقيقه
الارتكابات والانتهاكات التي يمارسها
الاحتلال بحق المدنيين وفي حق الصحفيين
هذه محاوله اسكات مستمره نراها مكثفه بشكل
كبير في غزه نحن في لبنان شهدنا عددا منها
ولكن المسار الصحفي
ومسار الحديث عما يجري اكان داخل فلسطين و
من قبل الصحفيين ومن قبل الناشطين هناك
ايضا وحتى في جنوب لبنان اظن ان اسرائيل
غير قادره على مواجهه هذا الزخم وهذا
العدد وهذا الايمان بهذه القضيه ايضا كيف
اثر عليك الاستهداف كارمن
من الناحيه المهنيه انا اكثر عزما واكثر
اصرارا على العوده الى الميدان لن اسمح
لصاروخ ان يحرف مسارا اخترته منذ سنوات
مرتبط بالانسان بالحديث عن معاناه هذا
الانسان وبالحديث عن ما يجري في جنوب
لبنان من استهداف للمدنيين من استهداف
للصحافيين هذا مسار انا اخترته منذ سنوات
وقررت ان يكون عنوانه الانسان
مهما كان دينه مهما كانت جنسيته او عرقه
واريد الاستمرار فيه اليوم اكثر من اي وقت
المضى استهدافات المتكرره للصحفيين يجب ان
تتوقف واظن ان
علينا ان نشكل ربما لوبي
من الصحفيين في مختلف بلدان العالم للضغط
على المؤسسات للضغط على الحكومات
لتعزيز تطبيق القوانين الدوليه اليوم هناك
قوانين دوليه تضع او تصنف استهداف
الصحفيين ك جرائم حرب ولكن هذا الامر لا
يحصل نحن في الجزيره خسرنا قبل فتره زميله
عزيزه هي شيرين ابو عاقله ونرى ان الافلات
من العقاب سم اساس باتت حين يكون الملف
مرتبط باسرائيل اذا اليوم نحن كما نبحث عن
عداله ونحاول من خلال عملنا ساء هذه
المبادئ والاحتكام لها ايضا علينا
كصحافيين ان نؤازر بعضنا البعض في كل
انحاء العالم لنوقف هذا المسلسل من
الانتهاكات او لنحاول الضغط باتجاه ايقافه
ايضا هناك اهميه لان اذا كان لدينا قانون
لا يطبق فما اهميته ما اهميه كل القوانين
قوانين الحرب التي تضع اطرا للحرب
وللتعامل في الحروب ما اهميتها اذا لم تكن
تطبق اذكر جيدا انا كنت في المستشفى حين
استهدفت عائله وائل كان الامر صعبا
للغايه هند هذه الشظايا التي هي في اجساد
عائله وائل هي نفسها في جسدي هي نفسها في
جسدي شيرين ابو عاقله ولكن بعيدا عن هذه
العاطفيه وبعيدا عن هذا الالم ربما وهذا
الصبر وائل علمنا اياه حين عاد الى
الميدان
و ليقول
وليتحمل غزه ويقول ما يجري هناك منكم
نستمد القوه منكم نستلهم الصبر ومنكم
ايضا ومعكم نستمر في هذا المسار
لان هذا المسار هو مسار اخلاقي مرتبط بقيم
الانسان التي نقف نحن اليوم لتعزيزها
وتثبيتها هذا مسار يبدا من غزه غزه قلبه
ولكن يمتد الى جنوب لبنان والى كل رقعه في
العالم